Bonjour et bienvenue
Dans ce qui va être...
le plus grand match de l'histoire de cette chaîne youtube.
c'est super chiant j'met des espaces entre mes mots, c'est infernal.
Aujourd'hui on joue, avec Mika, contre
Yann et son binôme Greg. Yo
Fermez-là, fermez-là.
On est sur
Disc jam
C'est un jeux que Yann a découvert.
Ça s'apparente un peu à ... comme le jeu dans les salles d'arcades ... à base de ..... le palet sur de l'air.
Yann : Le Air-Hockey..
Le Air-Hockey voilà exactement.
Merci de me faire passer pour un gros gogole devant ma communauté, je t'aime
2 contre 2,
Yann et Greg on au moins 58 heures de jeu chacun
Voici une photo du setup de Mika...
Voilà actuellement dans quelles conditions il est pour jouer
On fait ça en BO5, 5 match
Le premier qui gagne 3 match a gagné, c'est parti !
Mika on est en bas et les adversaires sont en face
MIKA put**n mais le mec !!
Mika : Mais t'inquiète t'inquiète c'est des feintes c'est des feintes
Mika : Mais qu'est ce que tu fais ?
Mais c'est toi ! qu'est ce que tu fais ?!?! PUT**N Mais Mika !
Mika : Mais c'est de ton côté là !
Mika : Oh la passe ! Oh ils ont rien vu !
Oooooh
Oooh la passe ! La passe !
Oh Mika ça joue tellement vite c'est incroyable !
Nan tu peux pas ! *Hahahaha*
Ils se sont pris la pire balle du monde !
Eeeuuuh !
Yann : Vas-y t'es placé !
Oooh Naann !
JOOLIIII !
Aaaaah
On s'fait démolir...
Greg : Yeaah Vas y vas y
*BOUM*
Mais Mika tu fais quoi là ! Regarde !
J'suis obligé de te Backuper ! J'ai pas confiance en toi !
J'ai pas confiance en toi du coup on perd !
NAAAAANNNN !!!!!
Mika on perd un set Put**n !
Tiens Mika !
Mika : C'était beau C'était beau !
Mika put**n mais Mika
Steplaît joue bien !
Mika : Mais attends
Mais mec ! J'avais la balle !
Oh Mika GG ! Allez on est on est bien on est bien on est bien
On continue, on continue comme ça oui Mika !
Allez la passe la passe la....
NAAAN !!!
MIKA ! Regarde ce que tu me fais faire avec mes jambes !
Mikalow, il va falloir que tu gagnes là si ils gagnent le 16, ils ont gagné
Mika : T'inquiète t'inquiète...
Yann : Holalalalaaaa...
T'inquiète t'inquiète...
Vas-y !
Yann : GREG !
Mika : C'est moi !
OUI ! OUI !
Yann : OH OUIII !
NAN MIKA NAN !
Mika on a plus le droit à l'erreur ou on perd le 1er match !
OH OUI !
*Hahahaha*
Yann : Tu pouvais l'avoir là !
Greg : J'avais confiance en toi...
Mika, Mika mais t'as pas honte mais t'as pas honte !
Mika : Eh non c'est de ta faute là !
Mais c'est de ta faute ! Replay !
*Musique Triste :( *
Bon c'est pas grave... 1 match à 0, Mika c'est pas grave
Ils ont beaucoup jouer au jeu contrairement à nous !
On peut remonter !
Après j'avoue le mec de droite pour son style méritait de gagner quand même...
*Gémissement de porte qui s'ouvre*
Mika : Moi j'attendais ton skill là !
MAIS PRENDS-LA MAIS PUT**N MIKAAA !!!
Mais c'est pas possible put**n j'en ai marre
Greg : J'AI !
Voilà voilà Mika c'est ça qu'on veut !
Yann : OOOHHH !
ÇA Y EST MIKA SE RÉVEILLE !
MIKA SORT DU COMA !
Mika : OH IL M'A BRAIN !
Mais nan j'étais dessus ! y a un bug !
Allez Mika !
Mika !!
Mika !! On se concentre !
Yann : Oh oui !
UAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHH !!!!!!!!!!!
*HAHAHA*
OH MIKA !
OAAAHAHAAH !
OOH CE QU'ON A FAIT !
AHAH
On est bien On est bien Mika On est bien, on est bien
On renvoie ça Illico Presto
Y'a confusion chez l'ennemi !
*Cri de la mort : UAAAAH *
Mika : J'AI !
OOH !
Vas-y Mika !
*DOUBLE KILL*
Y'en a un qui renvoie et l'autre qui va dedans Mika put**n !
MAIS PUT**N !!!!!!
MAIS C'EST TOI QU'ES NUL !
Put**n Mika Si on perd... Si on perd j'te bute !
Greg : C'est la victoire là !
Mika : Mais quelle victoire ?
*ONE SHOT*
Mika maintenant on n'a plus le droit de perdre un match
Tu as conscience de ça ?
Mika : Ouais mais faut mettre un peu de difficulté.
Ok...
Greg : Est-ce que ça va être le 50-0 ?
Greg : NAAN !
VOILA, KARMA KARMA DANS VOS GEULES !
1 V 1 !
*BOUM*
MAIS MIKA À QUOI TU SERS !?
MIKA À QUOI TU SERS DANS CETTE VIDÉOOOOOOO !!!!!!!??????
Yann : 'Tain mais Greg passe-la-moi !
Ouais ! Faut qu'il y ait du conflit en face là !
Faut que ça s'embrouille un peu au sein de l'équipe !
Mika : C'est lui qui dit ça après 1 heure de conflit !
Mais ouais mais...
OH OUI !
*Rire*
Allez on commence à remonter c'est bien, c'est bien, c'est bien !
On s'arrête pas en si bon chemin, on s'arrête pas en si bon chemin !
OUII !
*Rire*
Yann : OUI GREG C'EST BON ÇA C'EST BON ÇA !
MIKAA !
Là y'a juste eu du lag pardon excuse-moi !
*Rire*
Aller, fais gaffe Mika,
Plus le temps passe, plus là celui qui gagne il va gagner vla les points hein !
Oh Putain !
CELUI QUI GAGNE CELLE-LÀ...
AAAAAAAHHHHAAAAHHHH !!!!
Oh non on aurait gagné Mika....
C'est pas 'rave C'est pas 'rave C'est pas 'rave...
Yann : YAAAH !
OH PUTAAAIIIN ! L'EFFEEET !!!
Mikaaa ! Naannn...
Les amis !
On a identifié le problème !
C'était pas un problème de skill...
C'était un problème de Personnage !
Pffhfhffffhhff...
La fille est pas très forte dans le jeu !
Gros Bull-Shit !
Du coup, Mika a pris un autre perso, il a pris lui !
Bah voilà, j'ai même pas eu le temps de le montrer...
Merci Yann
Moi je sens que celle-là je vais la gagner
En plus celui qui gagne celle-là il a tout gagné !
C'est pas moi qui l'ai dit !
Greg : Vas-y Yannou !
Attention à côté MIKA !!
P*tain...
c'est pas grave, ils ont gagné un set ...
Rien n'est impossible !
Rien n'est impossible
Putain Mika on transpire la
Mika, on transpire là ... (Mika : Mais je rame là il l'fait tout seul)
Mais Naaaaan, rame pas Mikaa il faut pas que tu rames
(J'PEUX PAS LA LANCER TELLEMENT J'RAME)
Ohh tu l'as mis!!!  (rire flippant)
tu l'as mis en ramant (suite du rire flippant)
Eh attends on va peut-être gagner le set Mika, on va peut-être remonter, c'est incroyable ce qui se passe !
OUI, OUI ! Un set partout !
Oh putain, on va gagner Mika, on va gagner la... la game qui fait tout gagner !
Oh ! Oh p*tain ! *rire*
Oh le mec ce qu'il nous a mis !
Oh putain, allez il faut remonter Mika c'est  la balle de match de ouf là!
Mika : Non ! Oh oui ! !
Mika, Mika on a plus le droit à l'erreur Mika !
(Je tente !)
Oh !
Nooooon, Mika ! !
Nooon !
Attends attends, qu'entends-je ? Un sondage sur Twitter qu'un abonné a créé ?
Celui qui gagne la prochaine il a vraiment tout gagné ?
Les gars, vous pouvez pas refuser c'est une demande d'abonné.
(Moi c'est la... moi c'est la dernière)
OK ! *rires*
Oh, p*tain... allez, il a fait une balle de bâtard, nan mais il a fait une balle de bâtard.
Naaan, nan nan !
Mikaaaa, mika !
Mika par contre il faut vraiment que tu joues vite sinon il vont vraiment la gagner
Mika : Mais je joue vite mais ça tire pas !
La vidéo elle va s'appeler : quand tu joues à deux mais que ton pote bugue, quoi
Ah il se sont foiré, ah les blaireaux !
MIKAAA !
Mais fermez-la, vous l'aurez jamais le 50-0 !
Voilà, voilà ! Et là on remonte, Mika ! Et là on remonte, les gens crient dans la salle ! !
Non, un point Mika ! Un point Mika, c'est pas fini Mika !
Mika on se concentre ! *rires*
Pourquoi tu me donnes le truc, pourquoi tu me donnes les responsabilités ?
Tiens Mika !
Allez rematch, rematch ! Appuie sur A, appuie sur A, appuie sur A.
Un p'tit rematch les gars, vite fait !
Allez, allez ! Ubisoft veut bien nous donner de l'argent si tu...
Yann, si... si tu quittes, les gens te déclarent perdant.
Yann : Tu fais ton outro là, fais ton outro !
Si j'étais vous, et que j'étais abonné à la chaîne de Yann, je me serais désabonné direct.
Eh bah les amis, merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, on fait l'outro sans Yann
Attends, je vais l'appeler quand même, je vais l'appeler
Yann : Oui allô quoi ?
Oui Yann, bah, tu sais... on fait l'outro, tu peux dire au revoir si tu veux.
D'accord, euh... peace, urine !
Euh... très bien, à bientôt Yann !
Les amis, la morale de cette vidéo est très simple :
Si votre ami a un set up... comme ça, euh... refusez de jouer avec lui, vraiment. *rire*
Après ça fout la haine !
Allez à bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien ciao tout le monde, peace ! Merci Greg !
(Greg : De rien !)
C*nnard.
*Musique de fin*